hello everyone this is hi-hi and this is  my MSX story I grew up in China a school  I excelled in math and Natural Science  after graduation I work in industries  which were largely male dominated and I  felt pretty lonely on that journey after  getting to Stanford I met with  distinguished female leaders and I also  sensed that sense of loneliness and that  they felt alone their journey  I was also inspired by how they turned  my loneliness into power by sharing and  by empowering other people MSX has  helped me by identifying my own  strengths and my own uniqueness by  helped me to raise my self-awareness as  a leader and by giving me a box of tools  I can reach into on my life journey when  I leave this program I'm committed to  share my own learning journey with a  much wider audience so that they can  feel the power of education here at  Stanford  you